[Music]
in November 1914 the Ottoman Empire was
really ill prepared to enter a total
modern war and this was a war that would
be waged primarily against the British
Empire and the Russian Empire at the
same time the last time that was done
was back during the Napoleonic Wars and
it didn't end up too well the Ottoman
state however did carry out a remarkable
general mobilization the reform of the
army that was conducted really quite
rapidly before the outbreak of the
conflict held up the administration the
movement of levies to the staging areas
and as far as we can tell at least the
Muslim Turkish population marched off to
war quite enthusiastically and
patriotically now the vast majority of
the population is illiterate so we don't
have letters and diaries as we do in
European armies to judge the overall
morale but certainly the political
classes welcomed Wars away to restore
Ottoman power and some of this must have
been communicated down to the masses to
account for the successful mobilization
throughout the war the total
mobilization was something like 2.8
million soldiers who put on Ottoman
uniforms between 1914 and 1918 and it
comprised all the subjects of the
Ottoman state one of the changes carried
out by the Cu P was to impose
conscription on its Arab populations as
well as its Christian minorities
primarily Greeks and Armenians they were
all swept up into the new Ottoman army
and while units were organized into
linguistic groups that is regiments
comprised of Greek speakers Armenians or
Arabs the language of command was
Turkish and the senior officers were all
Turkish what is also impressive about
the ottomans is that this army sustained
something like well over 900 thousand
casualties thirty-two percent of the men
lies died in battle it was an enormous
undertaking for a population that was
only about 18 to 20 million by our best
estimate furthermore uh the Ottoman army
never seemed to suffer major desertions
as you had in the austro-hungarian army
both in 1914 and 1916 and later again in
the Russian army were morale collapsed
with the outbreak of the Russian
Revolution in 1917 and where many
soldiers simply set up soviets shot
their officers and refused to obey
orders from Petrograd nothing like that
happened in the ottoman state even with
the outbreak of the Arab revolt in June
1916 associated with the rather romantic
figure of T Lawrence there was not a
massive desertion even of the Arab
soldiers out of the Ottoman army over to
the so-called Arab League army or the
the Arab nationalist army to oppose
Ottoman oppression and that is a
remarkable fact in that the the Ottoman
state could actually put this bad army
on the battlefield and it stood up
loyally on the whole now there will be
the ugly situation of the disarming of
the Armenian and Greek soldiers to
putting them in labor of the labor
battalions and eventually killing many
of the Armenians as part of the massacre
that took place in 1915 but we'll
discuss that in a later lecture but for
the moment the Ottoman state went into
the war with an army that was organized
into Corps there were 12 Corps
representing some 37 divisions and
probably an overall strength of about a
little over 200,000 men this included
both active and reservists who had been
called up the army could be doubled in
size given all the irregular forces they
had notably Kurds in the East although
the Kurds were usually more interested
in attacking Armenians or each other
rather than fighting the Russians you
had Arab Bedouin groups that were also
recruited that would act as axillary x'
in expeditionary forces that were
launched across gaza at british egypt or
would patrol the frontiers so the total
men under arms in
18:14 was somewhere on the order of
450,000 the problem was bringing these
men to bear now think for a moment of
what kind of opponent the Ottoman state
plans to take on with this military
force the British Empire at the time had
a professional army the BEF that landed
in France to support the French was only
about 60,000 soldiers however they were
superb professionals of the highest
order
British riflemen could fire with such
rapidity and accuracy that the Germans
assumed that they weren't riflemen at
all but special machine-gun battalions
that were firing on their infantry they
also had behind them the army of the raj
that is the British administration in
India well over two hundred thousand men
and that army of the Raj which comprised
British and Indian soldiers both became
the prime military force for British
operations carried out against the
Ottoman state and that would be in the
area that we now call Iraq in the lower
Persian Gulf is where the British had
their prime interests they wanted to
seize Basra and protect the oil fields
and in the defense of Egypt in the Suez
they also have the Commonwealth forces
to draw on and these were significant
forces
it included South Africans and
Australians and New Zealanders the
so-called Anzac Corps that would provide
so many of the soldiers in the landing
at Gallipoli in 1915 and is still
celebrated as the great achievement by
both of those Dominion countries New
Zealand and Australia the total
population of Britain was somewhere
around 45 million but the British Empire
was ten times that size over 450 million
so they're taking on a really awesome
power in the British Empire just in
terms of population in army and once the
British imposed conscription at the end
of 1916 the numbers would just mount
even more furthermore the Russians were
awesome the Russian population is
difficult to estimate the low numbers
run at about 165 million the high
numbers at about 180 million it is
estimated that the Tsar could put six
million men on the battlefield now most
of
forces would be concentrated in Poland
against the Germans but it released
enormous number of forces in November
based at TIFF list today tbilisi and
georgia in the caucasus to oppose the
ottomans and just think for a minute of
the ottoman prime ally germany what
germany could do germany had a
population of 68 million if the opening
of the war they mobilize 45 million men
of not 40 about 4.5 million men only
about half of the men eligible for
military service it comprised of 13
reserve divisions 26 first-rate active
divisions and 10 cavalry division's and
german german sorry those are Corps not
divisions it's 13 reserve corps 26
active Corps and 10 cavalry division's
and they were trained to the highest
level of proficiency so the ottomans
both these be their allies as well as
their foes we're really by far a much
weaker army this is not the army of the
16th century this is the army now of the
early 20th century and it was more than
just a question of numbers and soldiers
there was also the industrial capacity
and ability to mobilize population and
resources to sustain these armies and
here the Ottoman state fell very short
and several figures will give some sense
of the disparity and make you question
whether an army that was essentially
created to fight a war with Greece had
any business of trying to take on the
Russian Empire and the British Empire at
the same time even though they were
distracted fighting Germany one would be
railway capacity that was all important
for moving armies in the early 20th
century you do not have motor vehicles
and you do not have a VA ssin railways
were the way to move mass forces from
their staging areas to the to the front
lines and here again the Ottoman state
was outclassed British railway capacity
well over 20,000 miles German somewhere
on the order of 38,000 miles Russian not
too far behind the German
Ottoman rail capacity in 1914 was about
3800 miles a fraction of what it was of
the other belligerents and one statistic
shows that the Ottoman rail system for
the whole Ottoman Empire was only 1/10
of that of British India British India
is about twice the size of the Ottoman
Empire
so moving forces around was a problem
just just in length but what was more
significant was the density of the rail
lines the Ottoman railways were all
single track they were not double track
sections of the Baghdad to Berlin Mitte
railway had never been built
particularly in the passes of the towers
and the amana's mountains at that
strategic point where Asia Minor links
up with the Levant you had to actually
stop the trains unload them move them to
the next part of track move them stop
them load them again
the railway never got beyond Missoula so
the forces in Baghdad and Basra had no
rail capacity and what was worse the
rail line across Asia Minor stopped at
Ankara
and then went south east to Konya there
was no rail link from Ankara to engine
room and the Caucasus front which is
where the Russian army was located that
was 500 miles from Ankara to the Ottoman
Eastern Front and all of that meant 500
miles of Traver traversed by camels and
mules which would take a month to lead
either reinforcements or supplies and
munitions to the armies battling the
Russians on the chorus this is a
strategic nightmare in terms of
industrial capacity and financial
capacity the Ottoman Empire was out
clasped by all of the belligerents by
anyway belligerents from anywhere from 8
to 10 times and and the statistics can
just be cited to mount up that the
Ottoman state didn't have the financial
resources it didn't have the industrial
base and it didn't have the population
to be involved in a war of this scale
it's extraordinary they did as well as
they did and given these facts which
were known to the Allies they probably
thought the Ottoman state would be a
pushover and certainly it didn't seem to
perform so well in the first and second
Balkan Wars
but war is more than just a matter of
numbers and statistics and sometimes one
can beat the odds and always my favorite
cases Alexander the Great uh and then
burr Pasha probably had him in mind when
he undertook this war he was convinced
that he was the strategic genius who
could leave the Ottoman state to victory
well that gets us to the second issue
and that is exactly what was their
strategy in 1914 the war came up very
unexpectedly the war that they intended
to fight was probably a war against
Greece possibly Bulgaria to regrain
regain Greek islands and the regions of
Thrace and that was out of pouch the
Germans would not even hear of it
because Greece at the time was ruled by
a king Constantine who was married to
this the sister of the Kaiser and
inclined to the German side instead the
government in Berlin especially bateman
Hovick the foreign minister insisted and
the German staff both von ocher and
later von Falkenhayn that the Germans
that the Ottomans open up fronts against
both the Russians as well as the British
and that it would be an aggressive
strategy now this appealed to Enver
Pacha the idea of launching an offensive
rather than staying on the defensive
after all it hadn't worked back in 1877
and it could have worked in 1912 if we
knew where the enemy was coming from
that is if the Ottoman forces had been
properly deployed in place against the
Bulgarians you wouldn't have 95,000 then
being over won by 300,000 and so Enver
Pacha with his German specialists
decided to carry out a strategy of
offensive offensives and not just one
but two in 1914
early 1915 the idea was to knock the
Germans and British back and threaten
their positions by launching attacks
into the Caucasus taking Tiflis today
tably see and raising Muslim rebellions
in the Caucasus regions and to the north
where the oil fields were the second
priority for an invasion and offensive
operation was a
of course across the Sinai and the idea
was to capture the Suez Canal and
interdict travel between Egypt and India
and ultimately to Britain itself now
that would be an ambitious operation
that would require crossing the Sinai
and that was a major logistical problem
in both instances the Germans proved
very important in providing the staff
for planning these attacks as well as
the logistics and engineering side the
most important front was clearly the
Russians and Enver Pacha decided to take
that front on himself as soon as war was
declared the Russian armies moved out of
their Basin tiflis and entered into
eastern Anatolia and over an ottoman
positions in December of 1914 Enver
Pacha appeared on the eastern front and
he took personal command of the Third
Army this was an army that comprised a
three Corps one of them deployed
actually redeployed from Iraq it was
supported to the east by a second army
that was based on bitless and these
forces were to retake the area lost to
the Russians in the autumn and drive the
attack into the Caucasus and beyond
it was incredibly ambitious because it
would be a winter campaign and they're
campaigning in an area where the
Caucasus rate rise as high as fifteen or
sixteen thousand feet and on the
Armenian plateau the normal elevation is
some six to seven thousand feet above
sea level
furthermore temperatures are brutal 2530
degrees below zero and think of the fact
that this army was sustained by no
railway the railways system stopped it
on Conqueror and from the start of the
campaign there was all sorts of problems
in getting blankets and food and
munitions to the Ottoman armies that
were supposed to carry out a very very
complicated encircling operation that
was to encircle the first Russian
Caucasus army and repeat in the Caucasus
with the what the Germans had just done
at the Battle of Tannenberg and the big
difference is the Ottomans did not have
the railway system to do what paul von
hindenburg had done at Tannenberg that
is encircle the first run
in army and destroy it in the marshes of
East Prussia the result was the
offensive went nowhere by early January
the army was freezing
the Russians held carried out a
counter-attack and the Russians are
always good on winter offensive just
asked the Germans about that the result
is out of the three Corps that
participated one was virtually destroyed
the other took heavy losses and another
one virtually surrendered 1/3 of the
Ottoman army was used up on this futile
offensive operation casualties were
enormous and Enver Pacha ever true to
his Napoleonic complex left the army On
January 9th and trusted it to his very
able
uncle Halil Pasha who had to rebuild the
Third Army and return to Constantinople
and declared victories just like
Napoleon returning from Egypt and
declaring victory back in 1799 so the
Russians pushed back into eastern
Anatolia the Front's eventually
stabilized the the destructive fighting
that took place across Eastern Anatolia
and the Caucasus essentially ended up in
a stalemate by the end of 1915 the most
tragic event was of course the Armenian
uprising that occurred in on April 15th
in the city of Bonn in 1915 the
Armenians revolutionary group seized
power gained control of the city carried
out massacres of the Muslim population
the Russian showed up late as usual
occupied the city on them on May 20th
went after the Ottoman forces were
pushed back abandoned the city in the
summer of 1915 and then the ottomans
took their revenge on the Armenians and
this this type of seesaw battle across
the Caucasus front led to enormous
casualties on the part of the civilian
populations as Muslims and Christians
happily massacred each other as they
squared off on either the Russian or the
Ottoman side meanwhile in the Sinai the
operation went off superbly logistically
largely due to the effect the efforts of
Friedrich Chris Vaughn Christian Stein
who was the logistical officer and the
Ottoman army
arriving from the Suez Suez except it's
a tax were repulsed and they had to beat
a hasty retreat back across the Suez and
the fourth army in the command of Jamil
Pasha the former Navy secretary
essentially had to regroup and
reorganize itself in Syria the two
offensives had gone nowhere and had cost
the Ottoman state enormous number of
casualties by the end of 1915 the
British however had the strategic
advantage
the British had the Royal Navy at the
start of the war they were already
introducting Ottoman shipping all along
the Levantine Coast also in the Persian
Gulf
even before the fighting formally
started in early November
the British had seized the city of Basra
and had closed shipping in the Persian
Gulf by the middle of 1916 this British
naval blockade will have the same impact
on the Ottoman Empire as it did on
Germany and austria-hungary the
population would be starving and it
would be aggravated by a poor harvest in
1916 the British also had the manpower
and the money to strike where they
wished and in 1915 they decided on too
ambitious operations one was to march up
and take Baghdad and that was entrusted
to a man named Sir Charles Townsend who
would lead an army comprised
overwhelmingly of British Indian
soldiers who were to move up to Baghdad
and secure the ancient capital it had
great religious and political
significance and the other of course is
the famous Gallipoli operation there's
been an enormous amount of literature
written on Gallipoli and it's only
recently that a lot of issues have been
clarified and for those who wish to
follow up on it the works of Kim Travers
are fundamental to understanding it
Travers has gone through both the
Ottoman and German reports as well as
the British and the Allied and he's the
first scholar to look at all sides of it
several things are clear about the
operation
there's uh there's no doubt that the
British Navy which in March of 1915
tried to enter the Straits
head for Constantinople that the British
Navy was correct that the ottoman guns
and the mining were too strong that the
Navy would have lost too many capital
ships in an effort to take
Constantinople the Admiral of the
Mediterranean fleet jean de rivet
believed this was so and it's now been
borne out by the documents on March 18th
there was an attempt to force the
Straits there was a major duel in the
Dardanelles between the cities today of
XE bot and of Janaka Lee and the ottoman
gun guns were unbelievably effective and
that event is still celebrated in Turkey
today as sort of a naval victory day a a
corporal on the Janaka lee side of the
Straits the Asian sizes of the Straits
reputedly loaded and fired his gun
individually because all the other
members of his crew had been killed or
injured and knocked out one of the
capital ships the ocean and German
documents seemed to bear this out the
result was to land army forces seized
the Dardanelles and let the Navy enter
the Straits and take the city of
Constantinople or at least forced the
government to capitulate
unfortunately it's doubtful that even if
the Navy got to Constantinople that
would happen the three Pasha's would
probably simply relocate and the war
would have gone on this is after all
1915 it's not Copenhagen 1801 the second
point is it was never quite clear what
those landings were supposed to achieve
the planning was poorly done it was put
in the hands of Sir Ian Hamilton who did
not have the confidence of Kitchener who
was the war minister landings on the
western side of the Dardanelles were
carried out by the Anzacs landings to
the far tip of the Dardanelles were
carried out by British there was a third
set of landings on the Asian side often
not mentioned in the literature by the
French all of these landings could not
go off to plan there were all sorts of
logistical problems and the only thing
that could be good said about it is the
Allies had to carry out this naval this
amphibious operation to
learn all the possible screw-ups because
that had never been done before and
without Gallipoli Normandy would never
been possible in any event on the
Ottoman side the preparation was
incredibly good and again the Ottoman
army performed beyond expectation and
their Pasha swallowed his pride after
his defeat in the Caucasus he appointed
Liman von saunders as overall commander
in the so-called Gallipoli Peninsula and
that's that thin peninsula on the
European side of the Dardanelles he had
under his command many of the best
Ottoman soldiers including a colonel in
the 57th regiment
Mustafa Kemal and those are officers who
commanded the Ottoman forces knew the
area very well they knew Lee Wells they
knew the various local roads whereas the
British were depending on maps from the
1840s the British when they landed had
no idea where their objectives were both
Commonwealth and British forces were
dehydrated and exhausted because the
water system was not maintained and very
often the British got to their initial
positions and were too exhausted to push
on and simply dug in the idea of the
expedition was to seize a chi bat and
shinnok wholly clear them of guns and
mines and let the fleet come through
instead what they got was a stalemate on
the evening of April 24th 25th the
landings took place most of them
according to plan where they were
supposed to be and within hours the
Ottoman army reacted the British because
of all the logistical headaches and
screw-ups dug in and you got trench
warfare on the Gallipoli Peninsula just
as you had in Western Europe the
fighting was unbelievably brutal and
throughout the entire of the fighting no
Ottoman machine gun emplacement was ever
knocked out by British naval fire
repeated frontal assaults got nowhere
the famous one on the neck was was
publicized in
a very important Australian movie called
Gallipoli that was released I believe in
1981 and the result is eaten today when
you go to Gallipoli you will find the
cemeteries of the British and
Commonwealth soldiers and the Ottoman
soldiers are beautifully maintained as a
tribute to the sacrifice on both sides
and the Turkish government has been very
very good in maintaining that it was in
this battle that Mustafa Kemal made his
reputation in some ways he was very
typical of the Ottoman officers the new
generation framed by the Germans but he
was also an exceptional commander in the
very first day of the fighting on the
strategic heights of Gallipoli he told
his unit the 57th that I am NOT asking
you to fight I am asking you to die but
in the course of dying war will come up
and take the position and drive back the
invaders it was an inspired command and
an inspired decision it won the respect
of Otto Liman von saunders no easy boss
and the result is the ottomans checked
the British advance on December 20th the
British fleet evacuated the forces the
British took over 250,000 casualties the
Ottomans had taken 300,000 casualties
but Constantinople had held and the
ottomans had won a significant strategic
victory the other strategic victory they
won
came a little bit later and that was the
British effort to take Baghdad had
failed in November of 1915 in a series
of frontal assaults they had fallen back
to the city of cut they had come under
siege and on April 30th 1916 the British
Army actually surrendered and and went
into captivity the largest mass
surrender of a British Army since the
Battle of Yorktown by the end of 1915
the Ottoman state had pulled off aim of
military victories that no one could
have anticipated far beyond what the
capacity should have been the problem is
strategically the Ottomans were
had not altered the course of the war
the victories of the Ottomans had won
over both over the British and their
recovery in the Caucasus did bring some
minor advantages Bulgaria entered the
war on the side of the Germans and
together the Germans and Bulgarians took
out the Serbians and opened up a direct
rail link between Berlin and
Constantinople Belgrade was captured and
the result is supplies and munitions
could come to Constantinople but
otherwise by the end of 1916 everyone in
the cabinet in Constantinople could see
that the Empire was suffering from the
strains of total war
first the conscription system the number
of casualties sustained in the Caucasus
the ill-fated Suez operation as well as
in the defense of battles to hold
Gallipoli in Baghdad meant that well
over 300,000 men had been lost and it
was clear that the annual conscription
intake of about 90,000 men per year
which is the best they could do in a
essentially peasant society meant that
conscription could not replace the
losses that as you entered 1917 or 1918
the army was bound to get smaller and
smaller and this was no problem for
either the British or the Russians who
had so much larger manpower a second
important point is that the weapons and
the munitions that had been stockpiled
for a war against Greece were soon
exhausted increasingly the Ottomans had
to do one of two things they had to get
more and more munitions from Germany
that fortunately was eased by the
capture of Belgrade and the opening up
of a direct rail link but they also had
to start undertaking their own
industrialization and here there has
been some very very good research done
by young scholars this is the CU P made
a real effort to mobilize the social and
economic resources of the Ottoman state
to meet total war that included bringing
women into the workforce in significant
numbers changing family and child was in
order for women to become wage earners
it also forced them to increase
nationalistic appeals to get volunteers
and conscripts and in an attempt to
carry out industrialization projects
unfortunately the Ottoman Empire just
did too little too late and in contrast
to the new scholarship on the Russian
Empire some scholars would argue that by
1917 the Russian empires economic
capacity was in high gear and if the
Russian Revolution had not broken out
the Russians would have won the war now
that's probably an extreme position but
nonetheless Russia had the industrial
base that that that it could increase
its munitions and it's war production in
a way that the Ottoman state could not
and in that in that case there was a
real disparity between the Russian and
the Ottoman belligerence finally there
was the problem of food production and
so many peasants have been conscripted
into the army that by 1916 there was
clearly a labor shortage on the
countryside this would be aggravated by
poor harvest by the British blockade and
above all by the faithful order signed
on April 24th 1915 that ordered the
deportation of the Armenian population
and the result is there was a severe
labor shortage not only in the in the
agricultural sector of the economy but
also the communications so many
Armenians were killed and they were
instrumental in running the railway
system that even the transportation
system was beginning to break down and
that affected not only the army but the
delivery of foodstuffs to the cities so
as 1916 dawned it was clear to the CU P
to the cabinet and to the political
classes in Constantinople that they had
entered into a war that was now turning
into a fight for survival and what they
all knew as the new year gone in the
winter in January the Russians were
bound to launch another winter offensive